I'm literally thinking about running for
the governor of California you should
try I may try you should try and here's
why yeah I don't want the job right and
I think those that's an asset it is
definitely an asset because here's the
deal yeah I think I could because
California is out of go to the flash
mobs please
there's so many robberies in California
right now gangs of people run into these
stores and just
flash mob
well you call it Robert I would stop it
you call it robbery I call it how
Society has failed these people yeah I
guess let's put on our headphones to
listen to the flash mob
well
news right now
thieves have smashed display cases we
call them merchandise from Nordstrom
that's in the Westfield Topanga Mall
let's go right to Justice live in Canoga
Park now she's got the latest in there
believe the sanctity of our retailers
it's your producer as a woman yes
definitely frightening for Shoppers and
employees who were in the store at the
time as several thieves entered and some
of this it was caught on camera some of
it was good
we're searching for something yeah who's
to say they're not playing Finding Nemo
here's my issue with this they call this
a victimless crime but the reality is
it's violent there are people that could
get hurt right
no this is a victimless crime do you
think that's victimless yeah you really
believe that's victimized yeah you if
you believe if I was a cop I would say
I'm sorry guys how has Society failed
you yeah yeah yeah it's great but but
literally the D.A and people like that
are saying and I'm open to the debate
you know that guard was in on it yeah
the guard's absolutely Anonymous not
just because he's black yeah
but just because he didn't move right
just because he was waving and saying
hey what's up I'll see you at home yeah
I'll see you like you got my bag right
to what I told you to grab it's here's
the thing about when me and him get
together it sounds racist but it's not
but it's not no it's not that's the
thing but it's actually not I actually
think he was maybe a Dominican guy he's
your hearing thing yeah it's not what it
sounds like no no no he just wasn't
moving yeah yeah he was just kind of
like he was just kind of look at it
because he's not getting paid a lot I'm
not gonna die yeah to guard a tote bag
yeah they're saying it's a victimless
crime now take your headphones off
because now we can't ball that looks odd
yeah
people are running into these stores
it's Smash and grab people are going hey
it's a victimless crime lighten up who
cares don't worry about it it's a
brilliant crime you roll in with 40
people yeah there's too many people to
arrest right it's pandemonium and people
walk out with a couple of Fendi bags
yeah big deal well it is a big deal he's
getting hurt a lot of people
a lot of people like who here's who's
getting hurt to me one person who got
hurt by this I got to prove it right now
yeah the people that are going to lose
their jobs when these stores close
because that's what happened in San
Francisco oh so everybody that works in
the store and then the store is
basically going to go we are not going
to stay here just like they did in San
Francisco what color are the people
working there everybody who I mean
is this even allowed on apple pie it is
I'm just asking questions I don't even
know I'm just saying that because look
at all the stories that are leaving
these are all the places that are
leaving San Francisco all the places
that are leaving okay right all the time
good times Marshalls Crate and Barrel h
m Uniqlo anthropology Abercrombie and
Fitch Nordstrom's Nordstrom sacks Gap
DSW now you're a conspiratorially
oriented guy so let me ask you a
question is This Disaster capitalism
will Naomi Klein write a book about this
is this Blackstone intentionally
throwing these flash mobs in there so
the prices dip down I know they get it
going out of business sale wow they turn
it into one big Costco no I think it's
paralysis capitalism I think that people
are paralyzed and don't know what to do
and I think that we've gotten uh
ourselves into a predicament where
unfortunately the levers of government
events and bureaucracy are grinding at a
pace where nothing can get done and
nothing unfortunately there's no will
nobody has any will anymore to make
something happen right so people are
just stuck trying to be a good person
going like hey man I don't know I wasn't
in that store I wasn't affected I don't
live in downtown San Francisco I live in
Marin County I got a mansion I'm not
going to worry about it until they're in
my window right I don't think people are
worried about anything that's not
directly affecting them and I think the
politicians are just saying whatever
they have to say
um to seem like they're good people and
that they're you know uh evolved and
that they are considering all the Angles
and I think it's paralysis I mean listen
these are the wealthiest people in the
world it's weird they're letting this
happen I understand conspiracy theories
people going why are they doing this why
are they letting it happen right I think
it's paralysis I think it's people just
not wanting to say the uncomfortable
things you would need to say right to
fix this like that was a crime like
that's a crime that's that's the lead
like those people need to go to jail
right like people that are doing heroin
on the street are not just poor right
like people that live in tent cities in
many cases are choosing to live there
right and use drugs because it's an
open-air drug Market where they can
procure the drugs that they're addicted
to what you're saying those are
unpopular things to say right what
you're essentially saying is Optics have
become more important than reality 100
more concerned with the Optics than they
are the reality and we've created a
world where people are not affected
that's the thing people are not affected
by how bad it's getting in the next town
not yet they're not yet not yet not yet
not yet but here's the thing it it's
always it's like anything else right if
you ignore something and it festers it
becomes eventually a problem that has to
get dealt with Raisin in the Sun it
explodes well when people go all these
flash mobs what do you think drove all
those stores out of San Francisco
this [__] inequality and then by the way
if there's no stores people don't want
to live in a San Francisco right right
and then people I don't want to live
downtown my wife can't go to the store
my gay husband who's a twink can't go to
the store whatever it is we know
lesbians can always go anywhere no
matter what but there are people there
are certain people that are more
delicate and more more important in
society than lesbians let's be frank
they're Marines the gentrification sure
they are but whatever I know they can
they can pickle things and they can
throw a softball they can run a bar yeah
they can hit you with a back they can
build a shop fresh but I mean it's state
are they evolving culture let's be
honest yeah uh my point is
the reality is this is the beginning of
a rot in a city that comes to you know
it comes to to be a bad Omen for a lot
of things yeah so those are the people
that get hurt all the legislators are
hijacked by um gotcha politics
everyone's doing slam dunks on each
other yeah nobody's talking about policy
you watch these debates and local level
all the way up to the federal level it's
just all personal attacks now that's
right it's like we're watching wild and
out it's like a gift battle it's just
going like and you're going like all
right we're hearing about Hunter Biden's
emails or Hillary's emails or Trump's
indictment you're going does anyone want
to talk about policy yeah does anyone
want to talk about how we can stop the
mob from you know who has policy ideas
has there been a flash mob for food does
anyone run into like California Pizza
kitchens well this would go where's the
Because by the way everyone's just
talking about they're starving well
that's all AOC talks about these people
are starving and they are starving Fendi
bags are worth a lot and so they all
sell these bags right they sell these
bags now money for food groceries I will
say this they all did look thin if you
want to catch all those guys all you got
to do is put cameras on at Whole Foods
get the George Cascon thing up where he
goes uh you know he's talking about and
this is the D.A of I believe Los Angeles
right yeah and this is the D.A of La
when he's asked about these things
because by the way I don't really shop
that much so I don't you know you know I
understand
uh not caring about this right but it is
something where I look at it and I go oh
this is the beginning of something that
could probably
you know be weird so it's just hitting
you now that things are bad well no no I
just these it's a new the flash mob is
kind of interesting it's been around for
a long time it's been around for a long
time it's a little fun it is fun yeah I
get the appeal of it like by the way I'm
a human being I understand it's fun
going let's run in let's grab some [__]
and let's leave here's George gascon
here yeah this guy looks like a deer in
headlights I mean this guy is just he's
the D.A yeah
right now in the face of uh the flash
mobs yeah he's got soft eyes he doesn't
really know what to do yeah
and he's being asked a question and here
put on the um
put on the headphones yeah let's hear
what he says and you can hear them
oh God he looks like the old coaching
available under the law when there is an
arrest made
to make sure that this individuals are
held accountable LA mayor Karen bass
also spoke about accountability saying
in part quote those who committed these
acts and acts like it in neighboring
areas must be held accountable but not
everyone feels like local leaders are
delivering on that promise businessman
Rick Caruso said quotes I have heard
directly from small business owners who
feel defeated by the lack of
accountability for criminals what do you
say to the person who points a finger at
you saying that there are people in this
community who believe they can get away
with serious crime in L.A county and not
be held accountable well I would ask you
you tell him when you just heard me
speaking right now because I think you
have a responsibility also for
addressing it air we will use every tool
available under the law
get out there and make a citizen arrest
yeah why is this guy not in Miami yeah
sitting on a cabana yeah I mean he's
perfect he's like what are you talking
about we got a brother here you have to
visit yourself I mean we are here but in
America you know what's coming here you
come here they get the hat back
everybody have to be responsible for
what they do it we see the people we're
going to make they're responsible
we're in Los Angeles yeah yeah I don't
know what uh what that is what his thing
is why he's even why you see these
people don't care about they're
appointed these guys aren't is he
allowed Dia is elected he's elected he's
a little votes for this stuff they don't
know this is because I've lived there
five years who's voting and how long are
these terms and yeah comptroller is also
elected I can't tell you what he does
yeah right they recalled the guy in San
Fran this guy chess a Buddha they
recalled him they were like you are
really [__] up oh that guy he was
basically like telling people that we're
stabbed to get over yeah he was going
stop locking your store at night right
yeah